so how much of a threat does terrorism
pose to the tourism industry we're
joined by Tillman Brooke the head of the
nonprofit international security and
Development Center tell me first mr.
Burke exactly what the aim of these
terror groups is that targeting the
terrorism sect the tourism sector rather
in in places like Egypt Tunisia Turkey
the terrorist act in a very strategic
fashion they want to make us scared the
killing is just a means to an end
ultimately they want to destabilize our
Western liberal free societies and maybe
also want to say don't mess in our
backyards you know we're here in the
Middle East don't come don't come to
where we are and stay where you are and
and leave us alone
and that message seems to be getting
even clearer when when they target
Brussels all of a sudden temperatures
they're trying to strike as close to
home from our perspective as they can
and they're quite successful in their
own ways and in doing that and we give
them a lot of attention and and we let
ourselves be terrorized by these attacks
to a large extent if you take a look at
the global tourist industry though
tourists will just go elsewhere and and
and Europe's an alternative for them but
is it a safe alternative now I think the
risk of terrorism is overestimated by
most people we respond very strongly to
images and to emotions and the constant
media reporting about this topic affect
people's behavior quite significantly so
it's not just the attacks that's also
how we deal with the attacks which
effects our choices our consumption
choices and when you go on holiday you
don't want to have any bother you don't
want to worry about things you know you
want to have a good time so of course
that your choice of destination is
strongly influenced by attacks and what
about Germany it's been spared so far
yes it's a place people move to because
it's politically stable and for whatever
reason we haven't had large-scale
attacks in Germany which is good perhaps
our security services are particularly
effective perhaps with better integrated
Muslim minorities or perhaps we've
simply been lucky because I wouldn't say
it was unlikely that Germany was ever
struck so I think it's possible that
Germany will be struck as well but on
the other hand as I said before the
risk of an individual being a victim of
a terrorist attack is extremely low
you're more likely to be killed by
lightning in Germany than by terrorism
well what about the reaction that in
Brussels would you call it overreaction
the airport closing there for weeks I
think it revealed a lack of planning I
mean both the security services don't
seem to be very clued in when it comes
to coordinating with each other either
within Belgium or across Europe and
secondly the response of the airport
strikes me as as being or revealing a
lack of preparation you know it takes
them many many days to bring the airport
back into operation it would be
preferable if they had more contingency
planning and were able to withstand such
an attack and to go back to the normal
business as soon as possible that would
actually affect the calculus even off
the terrorists what same day turnaround
would that people or maybe a few days
two or three days should be a plan B for
resuming flights and and the check-in
mode and they shouldn't be so reliant on
this critical infrastructure compared it
to us to a place like Israel where
there's a lot more chance of an attack
the Israelis have a specific policy and
that they say we mustn't let the
terrorists dictate our our new cycle our
our emotions and so when there is for
example an attack on on a bus in Israel
the security services clean up that site
as quickly as possible so that within
hours you driving by you don't even know
that there was a terrorist attack that
same day on that site and and that is to
reduce the impact of terrorism on
society it's actually quite a good
strategy and we haven't really learned
that lesson yet okay mr. quick lots of
lessons still to learn I guess thank you
very much for coming in today you're
welcome